[Music]
foreign
much or as little as you feel
comfortable but you know I've heard you
talk about
sort of being amongst that firefight
some of your guys get sort of peeled off
and you sort of found yourself kind of
alone with one other guy correct
uh we were with a group so no I mean
let's talk about all of it so that night
we uh we had gone after the number one
leader for uh Al Qaeda and the ambar
province a guy we'd been hunting all
deployment
and we took down the initial Target and
nobody was there uh found a lot of
activity a lot of signs that somebody
had been there but we missed whoever it
was
we found weapons we found uh explosive
stuff like that so we had our EOD guys
we're gonna blow all that stuff up and
we thought it'd be a quiet night it's
like 3 A.M in the morning now Iraq time
and uh our snipers you know called down
and said hey
got a bunch of activity on another house
about 150 yards north of here we just
saw Five Guys run out the front door run
across street and hide in some
vegetation and we you know we had seen
that before you know the enemy doesn't
always you know recognize you know our
technology or that we have you know
individuals that we place around and you
know stuff to help us be able to see all
over the battlefield
and uh so my boss came to me and said
hey I want you to take this team take
nine guys uh eight Shields well it was
actually uh Seven Seals an EOD guy and
our interpreter so nine total and he
said I want you to you know go walk
these guys down let's go find out who
they are if they're hiding there's a
reason they're hiding
and uh
so we did
um when we we they were hiding in this
vegetation across the street from this
house and we came up from the south of
this vegetation the vegetation was
probably about I don't know 100
150 yards wide by maybe a hundred yards
deep and we started pushing through the
South into this vegetation to come up
behind these guys
and uh what's that vegetation like it's
like it dude it reminded me of like a
bamboo Grill it was super thick and uh
uh very crunchy meaning it was making
lots of sound which was terrifying
because my heart was pounding in my
chest like in any minute you know if
these guys have weapons and I kept
talking to the aircraft above hey do you
see any weapons negative we don't see
anything these guys are laying there and
you've been in tons of situations like
this but you I remember you saying like
you felt something was off about this
yeah I um my heart was pounding my
Spidey Sense was like going crazy
um and this is an interesting thing I
talked to people about that listen to
your Sixth Sense listen you know I
probably because what I did is I said oh
this is fear you know you're just afraid
so you know and often in my career I've
had to push fear aside and we continue
to execute which obviously is is a very
important thing in anything in life
but sometimes it's okay to take a step
back for a second that's probably what I
should have done I should have I should
have taken a step back with my team
leader who very experienced guy and said
hey what do you think you know I'm
getting a you know I something's off
like
and if he had said hey man I think we're
okay let's continue to execute based on
our tactics and we would have but who
knows he might have said hey let's let's
not do this was he feeling the same
thing uh you know he kicks himself also
I think he was feeling it but you know
we we had been in a situation like that
before you know where we had walked guys
down with our tactics
so you know it is what it is you know we
uh we push forward we had the aircraft
overhead
um the aircraft told us hey you're going
to miss the enemy uh that's hiding in
front of you or they're kind of off to
you right now so you need to turn to the
right when we did that our other three
guys two seals in our EOD guy were off
to the left we got separated that
becomes a super dangerous situation uh
because we call it a potential for a
blue on blue blue forces meaning you
know our force is shooting back at other
R forces
um
I know a lot of people know the Pat
Tillman story Pat Tillman unfortunately
was killed in a Blue on Blue situation
and it happens in combat a lot the chaos
combat if you're not very careful
so I was aware of this
um so now we're separated what we
decided to do to fix this problem is my
right flank guy was uh on the edge of
the field and he said hey I'm by the
clearing let's push out the guys on the
left blank now are closer to the Left
Flank and they said hey we can push out
and I said okay let's let's both go out
let's go to the North and then we'll
come back across the front
uh and we'll push back into the
vegetation and grab these guys who are
closer to the you know the edge you know
they were it looked like they were about
five yards from the edge of this
vegetation
so um when we did that
um
our our I was kind of out front at this
point with our interpreter and our guys
were kind of strung out behind me and
our last guy was my medic as he stepped
out of the vegetation
um so we're now
you know in the northeast corner our our
other guys are in the northwest corner
I'm now out front and I'm starting to
move
um West to link up with these other guys
uh on the western side can you see it
all or
well we were out of the vegetation now
in the vegetation no with our night
vision goggles night vision
um
Night Vision works very well uh
maybe three feet and out just because of
the way you have to adjust it I don't
know maybe the newer fifth gen or Sixth
Gen they have the ability to instantly
Focus they probably do back then they
didn't you kind of adjusted it so you
and I sit in here I would be able to
look at you and you'd be relatively
clear maybe a little blurry but out to
10 feet you'd be pretty damn clear and
that would all be clear when you're up
against like vegetation it's nothing but
this green blob and that's what it was
like in in that vegetation so when we
popped out yes we could see again
our medic literally stepped on an enemy
fighter uh and the fighter rolled over
and tried to engage him and he shot him
and that was what started this gunfight
I was I was now out directly in front of
the machine gun that opened up on me our
medic was initially shot uh he took
around
um
right below the knee severed both bones
dropped him
um
uh one of our other guys Maddie ran
forward and grabbed on to Luke and
started dragging him back
in front of the vegetation so the house
that they were in was probably I don't
know 100 yards off to the northwest
corner of this field
and other than that man there was
nothing but probably thousands of yards
of empty Iraqi desert
um across from the there was probably
about 15 yards away from us there was
kind of a large like tractor tire and
then there was a lone tree and our guys
my team leader and the medic ran behind
the tire and our other guy DJ he ran
behind the tree I was still out front
trying to lay down fire I also was super
worried about us shooting our other guys
I mean I was thinking about the angles
um so kind of funny the firefight kicked
off and and I'm like yelling ceasefire
ceasefire which that's a little bit of a
training scar
um you know in training incidents if
something gets dangerous you can call
ceasefire so I was calling ceasefire and
then I'm like that's [__] stupid bro
like we're in the middle of a gunfight
so that changed and I'm like yelling
into the radio make sure you know what
you're shooting at yeah um which was
also tough because we were shooting into
vegetation and you could just see muzzle
flashes all all over the place
um
I think that me yelling uh Drew
attention to me because it was at that
point that both machine guns turned on
me and I started getting shot up I I
bullets
when they go by they're moving faster
than the speed of sound so the the bang
you hear from a bullet is actually the
sound from it coming out of the barrel
of the gun but what you'll hear is
you'll actually hear a Sonic crack
before that bang because the bullet's
traveling faster but the the bullet is
actually breaking the sound barrier so
you will hear this crack when they come
by you really close you won't hear this
unless you're
right by the bullets or under the
bullets and dude it was like cracks all
around me and uh yeah I realized I was
in a bad place I started returning fire
and it was at that point that I got shot
the first time I got stitched across the
body armor and it was when I got shot in
the arm which I thought took uh I
thought it shot my arm off a lot of
people are like what would that feel
like
um everybody's hit their funny bone so
it uh you know you kind of get that
electrical input so it kind of felt like
that except Amplified by like a thousand
it literally felt like an electric like
a bolt of lightning hit me in the arm
and it traveled up and just spiked me
right in the back of the skull and then
I couldn't feel anything and what I
think probably happened is my gear you
know on the side of my body probably
caught my arm because I you know I shoot
right-handed so I reached over and I
didn't feel my arm and it was probably
just kind of sitting like this but I
because I had no nerve function I
couldn't feel anything I was like holy
[__] my arms just got shot off
so I kept shooting
um
and I I was super heavy fire I took
rounds like like I said off my body
armor I took rounds off my helmet I had
my left night vision tube shot off I
took grounds off my right side plate I
took rounds off my gun
um I I turned at this point seeing that
the the guys had moved back to that tire
and I was like I gotta get back there
and when I turned to do that I caught
around in the face it hit me right in
front of the ear traveled through my
face exited the right side of my nose
blew out my cheekbone was left my
cheekbone broke and kicked out to the
right
um it it vaporized my orbital floor it
broke all the bones above my broke the
head of my jaw shattered my jaw to my
chin and it knocked me out and the guy
saw me
uh you know kept up and and fall and
thought I was dead they thought I'd been
uh robbing rightfully so they saw me get
shot in the head and they thought I was
dead
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something I'm I'm just super
proud of and uh again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become a part of
this community look I already board Bam
Bam if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
idea was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and given the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tuned in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stunt
coordinator from The Punisher he's
coming all the way up because we're
about to get after it and when that's
done he asked me in the car are you
gonna have my shake ready and I know
what that means am I gonna have my son
Warrior Shake they've got the active
protein but they also have this collagen
protein which is amazing they also have
the warrior blend which is a little bit
lighter if you're trying to cut and uh I
believe in it I believe in that some
Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones
[Music]